i want to talk about you and about your
pitch for the country i hope you're
enjoying the beauty parade
uh yeah it is quite a long beauty parade
i have to say as well quite a few
candidates you convinced you'll make it
to the final two
i very much hope so last time i was an
outsider and against all expectations i
made it to the final two and actually
ran i thought a really good campaign and
i think there's all to play for this
time but uh great to speak to you
i'm keen to talk about your pitch to the
country uh in a moment but just first to
reflect uh on boris johnson who of
course uh stood down this week uh you've
said that you stayed out of the boris
bubble do you think he's a man of
integrity
well i think there were questions um but
i don't want to dwell on that because
we've made a decision as a party that we
needed to respond to the anger of
many many voters and that's why we're
we've made that change and we're having
this contest and and we're going to move
forward
uh talk about moving forward with boris
johnson get a job in your cabinet if you
do become prime minister
well i think um he's not the kind who
likes working for other people and i
think you know
his era as prime minister and at the top
of british politics has concluded and he
has changed our history
and we now need to make uh the huge
change that brexit was a terrific
success and
and that's why i agree with people like
tom dugandar and other candidates who
said that the big question is how we get
the economy growing
i'm of course the the person who is an
entrepreneur i ran my own business and i
want to have a pro-enterprise
environment so um i'm also someone who
thinks that we shouldn't just stop the
corporation tax rises i think we should
cut them so that they're the lowest in
europe and north america but i also want
to do other things so that
young people do what i did which is i
was one of the only people in my year
group in university who went on to start
their own business i want other people
to do what i did because that's the way
that we'll create the wealth that will
pay for
tax cuts for families but also for big
institutions like the nhs that are so
important for us
and you talk there about tax cuts let's
be really specific shall we what taxes
would you cut and how much would it cost
well let me say
first of all to frame those comments no
conservative should promise unfunded tax
cuts because an unfunded tax cut is just
an increase in borrowing that's paid for
by future generations but i also think
no conservatives should raise
taxes
so the cut the cuts i'll make they're
not particularly retail sky
viewers may
say well are these really the most
important taxes but corporation tax is
the tax that matters most to businesses
and defines whether we are a
pro-enterprise
economy and we're scheduled to increase
the corporation tax to be higher than
japan america france or germany i want
to cut it to 15 the lowest we're able
we're allowed to cut it to according to
international agreements
because i want to send a signal that i
want people to be entrepreneurs to do
what i did that's that's how we're going
to get the growth
how much would it cost uh cutting poor
question tax to 15
yeah
so i've we'll be publishing all our
costings but i can tell you that we can
afford to do it within the fiscal rules
that we have
over a five-year period that means that
debt has to continue to fall as a
proportion of gdp and one of the reasons
for that is because a corporation tax
according to the treasury's own figures
you get half the money back because of
increased business activity and that's
why
look it's not the most sexy of cuts but
it just matters in terms of getting our
economy moving and
that's what entrepreneurs like me feel
very strongly about it does feel a
little bit like um some of the
leadership candidates having their cake
and eating it though you know there's a
lot of talk about tax cuts being flung
around but no one is necessarily talking
about the flip side of this which is
perhaps cutting spending or increasing
borrowing would you be prepared to do
either of those two things
i think we have to follow the fiscal
rule that says that over the over the
fiscal period debt should be falling as
a proportion of gdp we should be
reducing the burden on future
generations and that's why i'm not
promising uh some of the tax cuts that
other people have promised i do think
the nhs needs the 12 billion a year uh
that that we're getting from the health
and social care levy much as i said the
rise of national insurance then you
wouldn't reverse that
i i would i i would have actually uh i
hope i might have found a way to have
found that 12 billion
without doing it but we are where we are
and i think the priority now is to go
for growth for the economy but what i
would say
because i think you want to ask what's
different about me um i i'm the longest
serving cabinet minister of all the
people who are in this leadership
contest and i think that's
given me
the experience to know that it's very
important for trust in politics that you
only promise things that you really can
deliver and that's why what i'm offering
has been very very carefully thought
through
another uh part of your
political background is the fact that
you of course supported uh rebaining in
the european union is that a problem for
you with the membership
no because um that issue is settled and
what they care about is how we make a
success of brexit
and as someone who set up a technology
business i've always thought our big
opportunity is to be the world's next
silicon valley
and that will create enormous wealth and
we can do that because we have fantastic
universities great entrepreneurs
brilliant scientists
so we need to use our brexit freedoms
which
doing that is easier following brexit
use those brexit freedoms to really
turbo
economic growth and that will you know
settle our our economic destiny for this
century if we can pull it off
is it right that you'd have s mcveigh as
your deputy
yes i would and the reason for that is
because i recognize that leaders of
political parties need to win elections
and that means having an appeal broader
than any one person can have and i work
with esther in cabinet she was a
brilliant cabinet minister but she's
also one very tough elections against
labor
in the north uh just as i have won very
tough elections against the lib dems in
the south and together we will be a
formidable campaigning team that will
win the next election for the
conservative party
how about just looking at a couple more
policy uh things that are potential
flash points i guess um rwanda do you
support the current policy
on sending some asylum seekers to rwanda
i do but we've got to make it work and
i'm not convinced it is working at the
moment but we have to be honest that
migration has become massively more
mobile um over the recent years in a in
a globalized world and therefore if we
want to be a humane country that offers
a safe haven for people who genuinely
need asylum then we need to find
legal safe routes for people to come
here
not a mad dash for people to
put their lives in the hands of people
smugglers and try and get across the
channel
there's also been quite a lot of talk uh
among some of your rivals i guess about
the so-called war on woke there's some
culture
issues as well some kind of cultural war
issues
foremost of course the discussion over
trans rights
in your view are trans men men and are
trans women women
well i think we have to deal with this
issue with a great deal of compassion
but biological sex trumps and we need to
be clear about that and the broader
point i would make about
uh
you know about woke issues is that we
can as a mature democracy have a
sensible tolerant debate about these
things what is not acceptable
is to cancel people who have different
views to you because what has made this
country great
is our belief in open societies and
having uh debates and discussing these
issues openly and then you come to the
best answers
uh okay um
just looking at the contest ahead you
still have to go down sophie i'm sorry
i've got it
okay
one just to squeeze in very quick last
one who do you see is your biggest rival
in this race
well i think it's very difficult to
answer that question because um
there are so many people if someone has
just joined the race this morning i
gather um and uh i think it's a very
wide open field but what i what we found
in the last race
is that things get winnowed down very
quickly and and i'll soon find out the
answer to that question and i'll come
and talk about it then sophie okay thank
you very much jeremy hunt thank you very
much for being on sky news today
a little interview with uh jeremy hunt
to bring you there we can talk i think
straight away with our deputy political
editor
sam coates um what did you make of the
jeremy hull interview
well all morning this morning sophie
we've been assessing the tory leadership
candidates really on three criteria
uh demos uh
personalities and their experience uh
what they're saying about tax and on
brexit and i thought on all three jeremy
hunt uh was interesting he's emphasizing
two points about himself first of all
that he wasn't as he puts it part of the
boris bubble so he pretty openly
criticizes the uh outgoing prime
minister uh and doesn't make too many
bones about it but wants to emphasize
his experience he talked about being the
cabinet minister in this race or former
cabinet minister with the longest amount
of experience incredibly i was just
checking his record sophie and he became
a cabinet minister in 2010
david cameron's government when he
joined the culture department he was
still going in 2019 his final job was
foreign secretary so that's going to be
a key part of his pitch and a record
even longer than liz trust
um on brexit he's trying to uh
to make clear he is committed to brexit
interesting that he said he admired tom
tugan hat's point of view another
remainer another individual that'll keep
that northern ireland protocol bill
which europe don't like in place for now
but for how long it's very hard to tell
at this stage of the race and i suspect
brexit will rear its head at some point
as we get into the mp rounds of voting
but then we come to the question of tax
and that was really i thought the most
interesting uh part of the pitch from
jeremy hunt to you just now we've had a
slew of other tory candidates this
morning who've come on and said i can
promise income tax cuts i can promise to
reverse the national insurance rights
not jeremy hunt he's saying look if
we're going to take tax cuts it's going
to be business taxes in the form of
corporation tax he wants to bring that
down to 15 percent uh and he thinks that
they can do that within a fiscally
responsible in other words without
busting the budgets without borrowing
too much uh while preserving uh the
public finances even though he doesn't
quite say uh how he's going to pay for
it yet that is a dividing line uh now we
have rishi sunak i believe and jeremy
hunt on one side of that dividing line
saying we can't just throw money at the
public and then all the others that
we've been talking to this morning
including grant chaps including tom two
hat saying we've got to put money in
people's pockets right now the question
is do tory mps like the uh responsible
vision or the generous vision and a lot
of this leadership contest is going to
turn on that question
uh really interesting and sam i gotta
ask as well i don't know what you think
but you know with previous leadership
races i've had a rough idea who's gonna
be in the final two or at least the
final three with this one look it's
clear that richie sudak's got more mp
backers than the other candidates but
after that things are really pretty
split aren't they i'm finding it very
difficult to call
oh god i have no idea how to call it i
couldn't even tell you roughly what
order mps are going to go out you
mentioned rishi tsunami yes he's got
more uh tory mp backers than anybody
else he's also got a bigger anti-richer
campaign he's got the biggest number of
enemies that i can see of any of the
various members the people who worked
with boris johnson seemed to be gunning
for him i thought jacob rees-mogg when
he spoke to him was uh maybe not by name
but it was pretty clear he wanted a
different approach in the treasury
better political management he was
laying it thick taking out his his his
guns and poisoning that rishi soon so
rishi sooner has more mps for him but
more mps against him um is the question
of whether you served with boris johnson
going to work in your favor or against
you
is the position of brexit going to
become existential uh do people uh in
the tory mp ranks decide that they want
tax cuts now or that just isn't a
responsible approach uh when we when we
left this off uh on thursday when boris
johnson had said he had resigned and mps
were going back to their constituency
for those that i talked to they didn't
know the answer to any of those
questions which is why in the next eight
days or so
literally anything could happen i'm
going nowhere there are bookmakers